elle nous sommes avec françois chouet
ancien général de brigade et expert en
géostratégie bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors le discours d' emmanuel
macron est en cours mais on viens de
l'entendre ces quelques déclarations
notamment concernant la russie la
défense européenne ne pourra se faire
sans la russie
je crois qu'on est dans la ligne du
président macron depuis plusieurs mois
il ne veut pas fermer la porte ou du
moins ils veulent à rouvrir avec la
russie malgré quand même la crimée et
l'ukraine se ce qui d'ailleurs implique
pour les états d'europe centrale
justement quelques doutes ou quelques
rejet de cette position française très
particulière et nous avons vraiment une
ouverture puisque on voit bien qu'on
peut pas rester sur ce statu quo alors
ils l'avaient promis lors de son
discours de lundi en pologne que les
intérêts des autres pays européens se
seraient prises en compte plusieurs
allées en de l'otan qui dépendent du
parapluie américain du parapluie
nucléaire américain s'inquiètent de la
politique de désengagement de la scène
multilatéral menée par par donald trump
emmanuel macron s'est donc adressé aux
européens
les européens qui ne peuvent pas selon
lui se cantonner à un rôle de spectateur
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
je pense qu on est toujours dans la
logique que macro nien qui est après ses
remarques sur l'otan il ya quelques mois
de 10 rebonds maintenant ça suffit
nous européens nous devons prendre en
compte notre sécurité
d'autant qu'on a une administration
trump qui laisse carrément temps depuis
maintenant deux ans qu'elle pourrait se
désengager de la défense de l'europe et
donc la réalité là c'est est ce qu'on
doit faire confiance à un allié qui
risque de partir demain nous avons
l'expérience de l'histoire on va pas
recommencer et il est temps pour les
européens qui se sont bien abritée
derrière investissements militaires
américains de payer le juste prix de
leur sécurité
macron emmanuel macron qui souhaite que
les européens propose un agenda
international de maîtrise des armements
l'union européenne
les européens doivent être trop actif
sur le sujet a totalement et je pense
même que le plan macro à des zombies
dans le domaine d'abord je remarque que
je ne les ai jamais entendu je n'ai
jamais entendu un président de la
république venir s'exprimer devant les
stagiaires d'école de guerre et devant
l'ensemble des états majors donc déjà je
crois que le signe que peut-être on
distingue pas dans le monde civil
efforts pour nous militaires
c'est que le présent à peu et vient nous
parler c'est quand même assez rare et
notamment vis-à-vis des jeunes
générations de sucs et comment dont les
armées dans 10 ou 15 ans voilà premier
point alors qu'est ce que cela signifie
très concrètement qu'il s'adresse
directement aux militaires moi je reste
comment est ce que vous le percevez à
moi je constate depuis deux ans depuis
la sphère du général de villiers après
cette erreur je dirais politique du
président de la république que
aujourd'hui on bute deux ans les signes
multiples envers la communauté militaire
ont été apportées ce soit dans le
respect du budget dans l'engagement dans
l'émission et la confiance accordée il
ya eu une erreur en juillet 2017 et le
prétend bakr on a bien vu qu'aujourd'hui
dans le monde dangereux dans lequel nous
vivons
les armées sont une ressource fiable une
institution fiable
ap le monde est de plus en plus
dangereux et c'est ce qu'on a évoqué ce
matin est ce qu'on n'est pas
actuellement c'est que il faut que la
défense soit assurée par l'ensemble des
européens et qu'ensuite que les
européens acceptent difficilement de
payer le juste prix
depuis le break cité et la sortie donc
du royaume uni de l'union européenne la
france est désormais le seul pays de
l'ue à disposer de l'armé atomique
comment se porte le général plus
généralement l'arsenal nucléaire
français emmanuel macron l'indiqué un
instant à l'instant l'arsenal nucléaire
de la france est inférieur à 300 têtes
et qu'est ce que cela signifie il évoque
aussi la nécessaire modernisation de cet
arsenal alors il ya plusieurs points je
dirais ça c'est complexe va pas
l'aborder en quelques minutes mais
simplement que l'armé nucléaire en soi
est une arme de nos emplois c'est à dire
qu'elle est là pour dire si vous malgré
ces jeux répond d'une manière majeure
qu'elle rappelle la dissuasion et la
dissuasion c'est une arme de non droit
donc comme on est 50 cents 300 ou 8 500
ou plus comme la russie ou les
etats-unis
ce n'a pas beaucoup de sens aujourd'hui
voilà la dissuasion en soit c'est tout
ou rien maintenant le risque aujourd'hui
ce que moi j'ai entendu dans le discours
c'est que j'étais un peu surpris
finalement de distinguer dans le
discours du président macron une
certaine inquiétude devant la
possibilité d'un conflit nucléaire à
terme alors en europe je ne vois pas
trop aujourd'hui en revanche c'est vrai
qu'on a l'exemple de la corée est
inquiétant le débat sur l'iran
donc on élargit un peu le spectre mais
dans tous les cas pour revenir à
l'europe ce qu'a évoqué je pourrais pas
votre question précédente d'ailleurs sur
la maîtrise des armements il est certain
qu'aujourd'hui la remise en cause par
deux et a uniquement des accords qui
assurent la sécurité de l'europe donc la
russie et les etats unis aux problèmes
de quel droit oserais-je dire ces états
se permettent de discuter de notre
sécurité sur notre territoire c'est ce
qu'a dit le président un contre est
clairement il a dit que si ça nous
concerne nous devons être un troisième
partie nous devons être associés aux
négociations
nous devons apporter notre point de vue
et c'est comme nous les principaux
concernés
la dissuasion nucléaire aujourd'hui elle
est toujours importante pour la france
oui 10% du budget au détriment d'autres
armements sans aucun doute oui mais nous
avons tous les termes compte est utilisé
aujourd'hui par le président la
république va justesse que tout ce que
j'ai entendu sont très claires c'est les
termes qu'on a toujours des justes
suffisance on ne veut pas stricte
suffisance on ne veut pas des passes on
n'a pas besoin de beaucoup d'armes
ensuite ça veut dire pour répondre à
votre question précédent de cash départ
est brute c'est que depuis 1995 nous
avons complètement abandonné les essais
nucléaires
après les derniers essais nécessaires et
m'a tendu testons sous format
informatique donc modernisons l'armement
nucléaire c'est prévu c'est programmé
oui parce que nous devons être crédibles
alors emmanuel macron continue de
s'exprimer en ce moment même sa vision
de la dissuasion nucléaire française
est-ce qu'elles diffèrent réellement de
celle de ses prédécesseurs
pour moi c'est une contourner dans la
continuité oui je dirais même plus on
l'écoutait tout à l'heure j'ai
l'impression de retrouver un message
gaullien avec une france au milieu qui
est capable de qui travaillent que les
européens qui travaillent avec la russie
comme ça a été le cas qui travaillent et
les américains avec une certaine
méfiance et quelques années et qui
aujourd'hui cette méfiance revient et le
mot confiance a été dit à plusieurs
reprises dans le discours du président
macron il veut rétablir la confiance en
europe avec la russie il veut rétablir
aussi la confiance avec des états unis
et tout ça pour assurer la sécurité des
européens
merci beaucoup pour votre regard
françois choses ainsi
les râles de brigade des experts en
géostratégie